ja und an silvester wird dann zum
abschied für die kanzlerin ein großes
feuerwerk gezündet
ach nee geht ja gar nicht
feuerwerksverbot das sind archiv
ausnahmen aus fast schon vergessenen
zeiten auch an diesem silvester wie
schon beim vergangenen er wird es wieder
ein böllerverbot geben beschlossen
gestern bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wir haben
mal rein
das sind
mindeststandards im übrigen haben wir
auch noch mal das feuerwerksverbot fürs
jahresende aus dem letzten jahr
wiederholt auch dass mindeststandards
für alle produzenten von
feuerwerkskörpern ist dieses so nebenbei
erwähnte verbot natürlich katastrophal
und zwar zum zweiten mal in folge
bleiben sie eben auf ihren kleidern
sitzen und das sorgt natürlich für wut
und frustration so auch bei florian von
das ist eine völlig katastrophal falsche
entscheidung die auswirkungen die das
hinter sich die raten schwanz der damit
sich gezogen wird ist katastrophal und
ist den leuten die dort anscheinend
offensichtlich überhaupt nicht bewusst
was hat das für die feuerwerks branche
für ihre branche für auswirkungen diese
entscheidung das hängt davon ab wie die
politik damit umgeht wie die politik
reagiert und was verhelfen sie zur
verfügung stellt das ist zum einen
wahnsinnig viel geld ja wir reden von
gefahrstoff lägern das ist wirklich ein
pulverfass was hier da veranstaltet wird
keiner weiß wo die ware hin soll wir
haben 50 prozent mehr als noch im
vorjahr das ging noch gerade so auf
biegen und brechen jetzt stehen keine
lehrer zur verfügung von nicht nur das
feuerwerk kennen muss sondern auch noch
ganz andere sprengstoffe chemikalien
toxische stoffe hoch sensible stoffe
wofür bald die mitarbeiter fehlen werden
denn die haben keinen job mehr holen mit
dem zweiten feuerwerksverbot und es gibt
keine liga dafür wir plädieren dafür
dass die bundeswehr
gefahrstofflager per sofort zur
verfügung steht wo die ganzen sachen
eingelagert werden können denn sonst
landen sie sonst nur sind herrenlos tja
wir gehen mal alles durch was da alles
gestern beschlossen wurde bleiben aber
erstmal bei feuerwerksverbot bei uns im
studio ist
jan schäfer ja das war kein knaller wie
wir gerade gehört haben das war kein
knaller für ganz ganz viele
beschäftigte und hersteller was
natürlich ein knaller für viele menschen
die sich auf silvester freuen die auch
gemeinsam feiern wollen die vor allem
geimpft sind oder die möglicherweise
auch schon eine booster impfung haben
denn das feuerwerksverbot ist das eine
auf der einen seite es gibt auch ein
versammlungsverbot und was in diesem
papier auch drinstehen dass es natürlich
auch absolut brisant ist dass in
regionen mit einer inzidenz von über 350
auch die privaten feiern wieder
reguliert werden also selbst wenn mehr
als 50 doppelt oder sogar dreifach
geimpfte personen zusammenkommen würden
die sich auch noch vorher haben testen
lassen er wirft dürfte es eine solche
feier nicht mehr geben also selbst
geimpft und getestet ist dann in so
genannten hoch incidents gebieten a350
nicht erlaubt es absurd erkennt davon
letzten jahr da hat man zum beispiel in
berlin gesagt okay manche straßen lassen
wir offen bzw wurden so generelle
feuerwerke gezündet wird sowas
vielleicht dieses jahr geben oder kann
man sagen dieses jahr bleibt der himmel
dunkel zu silvester also wenn
feuerwerkskörper nicht verkauft werden
dürfen und böller nicht verkauft werden
dürfen dann gibt es möglicherweise noch
diese diese kleinen wie nennt man sich
auch feuerwerkskörper aber die also auch
ungefährlich sind für kinder entzündbar
möglicherweise so das steht aber noch
nicht ganz fest also das haben wir im
letzten jahr ja auch schon gesehen und
der eine oder andere der noch vorräte
hat aus den vorjahren kann die einfach
natürlich abbrennen aber auch da heißt
es das eigentlich darauf hingewiesen
wird dies nicht zu tun und dann gibt es
natürlich diese bereiche das hat andere
gründe in denen feuerwerkskörper auch in
den vorangegangenen jahren zum teil
schon nicht mehr gezündet werden durften
dass er aber sicherheitsgründe da hat
die polizei gesagt das was hier passiert
ist uns einfach viel zu gefährlich hat
mit dem was wir jetzt an begründung
haben aber überhaupt nichts zu tun hier
versuchte die politik jetzt doch mal
wieder ja epidemiologisch zu
argumentieren die wissen aber draußen zu
sein hat eigentlich wenig auswirkungen
darauf ob man sich noch mit corona
anstieg oder nicht so gut wie keine dann
wurde die politik doch mal dazu und
zugeschaltet ist der finanz und
wirtschaftspolitiker der fdp
bundestagsfraktion frank schäffler
hallo herr schäffler hallo chris i was
sagen sie geht dass ein böllerverbot so
weit ist das wirklich nötig
ich halte das für totalen unsinn die
erosion forschung zeigt uns ja auch das
im außenbereich die übertragbarkeit von
kommunal sehr gering ist eigentlich
müssten wir alle an silvester rausgehen
damit wir uns nicht weiter an stecken
also ich halte das für völlig
unverhältnismäßig vor allem auch über
das ganze land das zu ziehen ist
völliger unsinn denn wir haben ja sehr
sehr unterschiedliche corona situationen
im land aber romandie an dass sie denn
damit einen gemeinsamen beschluss auch
der künftigen ampel regierung na ja wir
haben das haben die ministerpräsidenten
erstmal geschlossen
und die neue regierung ist ja noch gar
nicht im amt dh das ist schon noch eine
aufgabe der alten regierung die jetzt
hier beschlossen wurde olaf soll die
attacke am tisch ja aber die fdp sei es
ja nicht mit am tisch und aber weil es
war abgeschlossen
das mag sein aber ich glaube am ende
wenn es darum geht dass das sprengstoff
die sprengstoffverordnung noch mal
geändert werden muss muss es durch den
deutschen bundestag da muss man
natürlich auch mal darüber sprechen
jetzt verlieren ja sehr viele branchen
unternehmer ihre ganzen einkünfte gerade
die silvester beziehungsweise feuerwehr
feuerwerkskörper branche braucht es da
auch einen neuen
finanzrettungsplan
attig muss man diesen unternehmen helfen
sollte das so kommen wie es kommt denn
ich sage mal die machen in einer woche
machen die fast 100 prozent ihres
umsatzes
und das kann man da kann man die nicht
im regen stehen lassen den muss man
natürlich helfen das kann man nicht
einfach so geschehen lassen das ist
jetzt schon eine katastrophe sie haben
das selbst in ihrem film gezeigt da geht
eine ganze branche kaputt da haben wir
schon mal weiter wir wollen mit ihnen
zusammen mal gucken was die menschen auf
der straße dazu denken was die von dem
böller verbot halten denn wir haben uns
einmal in berlin umgeschaut
böllerverbot an silvester wie findest du
das ich finde es sehr schade denn es
macht sehr viel spaß an die wäsche
böllern das finde ich nicht gut ich
finde es ganz gut wägen den tieren also
weil ich hab selber zwei katzen und die
haben halt richtig richtig angst finde
ich gut da ich mama bin und meine
tochter jetzt zwei jahre ist und jedes
jahr wach geworden ist da ist auch ganz
schön schallt in der stadt also finde
ich bin ich dafür im prinzip finde ich
das gut und ich finde auch gut diese
bereiche extra ausgeschrieben wo man
bekommen kann und vielleicht sollte man
bereiche auch ausschreiben wo man nicht
will dann darf das finde ich in ordnung
ich bin dafür dass es keine böller
silvester gibt die knallerei erschreckt
leute ich mich auch ich bin auch etwas
älter geworden die kinder ist es war
schade und es gehört zwar zu silvester
dazu aber ich komme auch ohne aus es
müsste ein bisschen ruhiger sein kleine
sachen ja aber die großen langen dinger
und rottländer anschließend china hält
sich mir an die zeiten ja und das finde
ich ein bisschen extrem ja einerseits
finde ich das in ordnung um die
belastungsgrenze der krankenhäuser nicht
überzustrapazieren und auf der anderen
seite finde ich das natürlich total
schade dass man mit freunden und
familien nicht so richtig feiern kann
mit freunden und familie nicht so
richtig feiern kann sagte gerade die
dame herr schäffler die große frage was
kann denn die fdp jetzt noch tun um
beschlüsse gefasst wurden gestern zu
stoppen oder möglicherweise zu
revidieren
ja wir sollten da auf ausnahmen auf
länderebene pochen denn wie gesagt die
epidemische lage ist da sehr
unterschiedlich im land man muss das in
sachsen anders beurteilen als in
schleswig-holstein oder
nordrhein-westfalen
und deshalb haben wir schon bei der
novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auf die länder
gesetzt dass die ihn spezifische
regelungen machen können und das sollte
man hier auch tun man muss sich das
ganze land über einen kamm scheren aber
genau das wird ja getan genau das ist ja
gestern beschlossen worden es ist eben
bundesweite regeln gibt beispielsweise
auch was die maximale anzahl von den
feiernden angeht bei privatfeiern nehmen
wir mal so eine silvesterfeier dürfen
halt in gebieten mit einer inzidenz über
350 dürfen halt maximal 50 personen bei
so einer silvesterfeier zusammen sein
und auch die müssen doppelt geimpft sein
der unterschied zum alten
infektionsschutzgesetz ist das beim
neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz der deutsche
bundestag und die länderparlamente
entscheiden und nicht die
ministerpräsidenten deshalb muss das
erst durch die jeweiligen parlamente
gehen können sie sagen herr schäffler
und das ist etwas was man im papier
nicht findet wie lange diese maßnahmen
eigentlich gelten sollen die gestern
beschlossen wurden gibt es da ein
enddatum wissen sie etwas also auf bei
durchsicht dieser fünf seite und der 20
punkte ist da nichts genau zu erkennen
das muss man natürlich ein bisschen von
der von der lage abhängig machen wir
hoffen wir alle dass es im frühjahr dann
wieder besser wird aber am ende muss das
auch im gesetz geregelt werden das könne
nicht die ministerpräsidenten einfach in
einer videoschaltung regel sondern das
muss auch gesetzlich verankert werden
das heißt sie fordern der deutsche
bundestag muss jetzt in seiner
sitzungswoche nächste woche darüber auch
abstimmen wie lange das was beschlossen
wurde gestern dann gültigkeit hat ich
gehe davon aus dass das so geplant ist
denn verschiedene fragen treffe neben
den bund und andere fragen treffen die
landesparlamente und die werden dann
entsprechend beteiligt und müssen auch
beteiligt werden jetzt wird der ire re
ihre partei dem nächsten der regierung
seien christian lindner wird neuer
finanzminister wie sieht es da aus haben
sie schon konkrete pläne beziehungsweise
wer wird da schon einen masterplan
entwickelt um die ganzen komas nahmen
die jetzt stattfinden zu finanzieren
ja wir haben ja einen bestehenden
haushalt er gilt ja auch nichts und es
wird sehr wahrscheinlich auch einen
nachtragshaushalt geben
und da wird man das berücksichtigen
müssen
ganz herzlichen dank herr schäffler für
ihre eindrücke